what's China's problem with the poppy  what does the poppy mean to the UK  remembrance but to China it means  something very different drug addiction  why it's all about tea 19th century  Brits loved tea but opium was the only  thing they could trade for staff China  made and back then made in China meant  silk jade porcelain and spices so today  chinese students a talk with the poppy  plus the british empire equals addiction  colonialism and warm which is why China  has a problem with the poppy so when the  PM in his team wore poppies in China  they caused a diplomatic incident and  that's because to the UK the pop you  means remembrance but to China it means  opium